[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fils l'essentiel de l'actualité est
local voici les titres en images de ce
13 décembre 2016 le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot elle vient
d'inaugurer ces nouvelles unités à
saint-cyr-l'ecole nous parlerons des
changements à attendre pour les usagers
selon mehr les skippeurs du vendée globe
ne sont pas coupés du monde pour autant
les blinois louis burton échange
régulièrement avec sa famille nous
entendrons son épouse nous expliquer
comment elle vit cette compétition en
mer depuis la terre ferme et puis plus
que onze jours avant le réveillon quels
sont les jouets que les enfants
attendent au pied du sapin le guide des
tendances à destination du père noël
dans l cette édition de la politique
pour débuter avec l'annoncé des
candidats socialistes pour les élections
législatives de juin prochain les
militants se sont prononcés dans les
différents départements et dans les
yvelines benoît hamon briguera un
nouveau mandat dans la 11e
circonscription
reste une inconnue de taille néanmoins
le résultat de la primaire de la gauche
à laquelle il participe en cas de
candidature en tout cas il sera opposé
une nouvelle fois comme en 2012 aux
républicains jean michel fourgous autres
candidats socialistes dans les yvelines
c'est nicolas eu le conseiller municipal
d'opposition des clayes-sous-bois il se
présente dans la troisième
circonscription est détenu actuellement
par henri guaino et puis du côté de
vélizy ses amours aux adjots ward qui a
été désigné il est actuellement
conseiller municipal d'opposition de la
ville
la convention nationale du parti
socialiste qui se tiendra samedi
prochain à validera définitivement les
différents noms le ps qui va jouer gros
également dans le département puisque il
ne détient actuellement que 12 des deux
que deux des douze sièges du pardon et
puis cette autre information jean
frédéric poisson annonce son départ de
la présidence de l'agglomération de
rambouillet territoire l'ancien candidat
à la primaire de la droite et du centre
a fait son choix en raison de la
nouvelle loi sur le non cumul des
mandats il a décidé de brider un nouveau
poste de député dans les prochains mois
le
de son successeur pour cette
agglomération du sud des yvelines n'est
pas encore connue élections le 31
décembre prochain
je vous le disais en titre le centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot de
saint-cyr-l'ecole or a inauguré hier
soir un nouveau pôle de psychiatrie
infanto juvénile sur les trois
structures de ce pôle deux sont dédiés
aux enfants atteints de troubles du
développement a les détails de ces
différents changements à attendre pour
les usagers ces nouveautés c'est avec
camille lambert 8000 enfants autistes
naissent chaque année en france
ici au centre hospitalier charcot de
saint-cyr-l'ecole la prise en charge de
ces enfants va être améliorée lundi 12
décembre le centre a inauguré son
nouveau pôle de psychiatrie infanto
juvénile qui était important c'est le
fromage que les québécois appellent le
virage ambulatoire c'est-à-dire au lieu
de subtiliser les maires ou les enfants
24 24 on les prend en charge soit
hospitalier moncton jour soit en visite
à domicile soit par des consultations
donc c'est une prise en charge plus
légère ça permet aussi de prendre en
charge plus de personnes parmi les trois
nouvelles unités l'hôpital de jour
united' et le jardin d'enfants
thérapeutique
toutes deux sont consacrés aux enfants
souffrant de troubles du développement
une quarantaine seront accueillis la
troisième l'unité parents bébé est dédié
aux difficultés qui suivent
l'accouchement
ça peut être un conflit de couple ça
peut être une mère célibataire ça peut
être une maman qui est porteuse d'une
maladie un enfant qui lui-même est
porteur d'une maladie
donc ça va 2 j'ai envie de dire de la
simple guidances parentale à de vrais
consultations psychologiques
pédopsychiatrie pouvoir voir un
accompagnement médical sur des
pathologies particulières
la dépression post partum toucherait 10
à 20% des femmes elles pourront donc
trouver un soutien si kia trick à la
place de l'ancienne maternologie de
l'établissement au total l'hôpital a
investi 230 mille euros pour les trois
unités
un mot du vendée globe à présent comme
régulièrement dans ce journal coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur le skipper
louis burton elle est originaire de
rambouillet alors qu'ils naviguent
actuellement dans l'océan indien sa
famille garde le contact avec lui en lui
envoyant des mails ou encore en passant
quelques fois des coups de fil donc par
téléphone un reportage
michael almy d'euros et de patrick
jacques de dixmude à 31 ans le skipper
louis burton vit actuellement son
deuxième vendée globe
laurent boli taille dans l'océan indien
sur son imoca bureau vallée le
navigateur affronte en ce moment le
froid venu de l'antarctique et les
baleines une baleine une balade sur quoi
aussi proche
sa cure en développant bouche pour dire
que c'est comme ça ça doit faire
plusieurs tonnes la baleine et le
skipper ils sont d'abord petit
petit un peu plus de 15000 kilomètres de
louis burton sa femme la navigatrice
servane escoffier vie la course entre
les studios de télévision à paris et sa
maison à saint malo en bretagne on la
vit surtout intensément et sans coupure
jour et nuit et on suit les moindres
classement
on attend le moindre e mail pour savoir
s'il a d'autres problèmes si tout va
bien et on on sait que tout va bien une
heure après tu peux avoir une grosse
galère donc c'est vrai qu'on se réjouit
de chaque 24 heures qui passent pour
communiquer avec louis burton sa femme
là au téléphone une à deux fois par
semaine et lui envoie environ 5 mails
par jour ça va aussi bien des raconter
ce que font nos enfants que de que des
parties techniques et puis aussi c'est
l'univers ban de le divertir de le tenir
informé de la vie à terre d actualité
louis burton devrait être de retour dans
un peu moins de deux mois sauf incident
le skipper est actuellement neuvième de
cette 8e édition du vendée globe
à deux semaines des fêtes de fin d'année
il est encore temps d'envoyer sa lettre
au père noël la commune de plaisir remet
chaque année en service sa collecte des
fameuse missive est que les enfants elle
n'hésite pas et ils recevront forcément
une à réponse un sujet signé anne laure
l'anguille
tous les matins anaïs tu ramasses le
courrier pour un destinataire un peu
particulier le père noël comme chaque
année la mairie de plaisir collecte les
centaines de listes de cadeaux de ces
jeunes résidents nous avons mis en place
la boîte à lettres du père noël afin de
donner de la magie aux enfants afin
qu'ils puissent établir une lettre et
nous leur apportons après une réponse du
père noël pour écrire au célèbre barbu
toutes les adresses sont valables pourvu
qu'elle soit un peu imaginatives
côté cadeaux les petits plaisirs wa
savent exactement ce qu'ils veulent
et pour être sûr que le père noël ne se
trompe pas il colle même des extraits du
catalogue publicitaire les enfants
demandent toutes sortes de jouets ça va
du jouet classique aux jouets est un peu
plus évoluée technologique
il ya toutes sortes de demandes ya tous
les âges on a même des petits de 2 ans
et les parents qui écrivent une fois les
lettres lui celles ci sont transférés au
véritable secrétariat du père noël à
libourne près de bordeaux cependant
plaisir enverra un courrier à chaque
enfant
après les fêtes lui recommandant
notamment d'être sage jusqu'à l'hiver
prochain
ah on a eu beaucoup de bons retourner
parents viennent nous remercier pour
avoir eu la réponse et les enfants sont
heureux et ils ont eu la sensation que
le père noël les à leur avait répondu
cette boîte aux lettres située dans les
jardins de l'hôtel de ville reçoit entre
150 et 200 lettres par semaine preuve en
est que la magie de noël n'est pas prêt
de s'essouffler et une fois cette lettre
envoyée au père noël reste le choix des
cadeaux à présent quelles sont les
tendances pour cette année 2016
reportage mais quel ennemi de roanne
lors l'anguille voilà mais voilà une
maman de plus qui craque pour la youkai
watch tête d'affiche des listes de noël
2016 cette montre n'a pas vraiment
vocation à donner l'heure mais coûte
quand même 25 euros heureusement quand
il faut faire plaisir le père noël ne
compte pas sans aucun doute sous le
sapin vous allez avoir
youkai watch donc c'est une montre dans
laquelle vous allez pouvoir glisser des
petits médaillons et l'enfant va pouvoir
jouer avec
au rayon des tout-petits compter un
budget plus important pour cette boîte
peau pas trop
des chiens aux allures de policiers qui
devrait faire fureur auprès des 2 5 ans
59 euros 99
il faut faire plaisir autre joueur phare
cette année les faux animaux de
compagnie profitez-en ses peluches
animées pourrait bien vous permettre de
gagner du temps avant de devoir acheter
un véritable compagnon à quatre pattes
suffit d'un pack de passer devant il
veut bouger pouvons bouger si vous le
secouer un peu il va se mettre à il va
se mettre à réagir
et puis s'il est content à ronronner
enfin si aucune de ces propositions ne
vous inspire rassurez vous les grands
classiques feront toujours la sphère
fois de père noël venu chercher une robe
de pain fait une petite fille qui va
avoir trois ans et je voudrais le
costume de réponse
on a aussi une grosse tendance cette
année avec les vingt ans l'anniversaire
des pokémon avec les jeux pokémon go et
puis les jeux de cartes en sortant pensé
à faire emballer les cadeaux auprès des
associations
un geste gain de temps qui servira aussi
une bonne cause conseils du père noël
on quitte le monde de noël à présent
pour terminer ce journal rencontre avec
une hauteur l'auteur du bruit du bonheur
c'est la versaillaise saratoga veine
elle signe là son premier ouvrage c'est
une histoire de secrets de famille
inspiré de sa propre vie même si le
roman n'est pas autobiographique
l'auteur était en dédicace il y à
quelques jours du côté de versailles et
nous l'avons rencontré reportage camille
lambert nicolas quere l'oit
elle aura attendu près de dix ans et
différentes expériences au sein
d'ateliers pour enfin se lancer
sarah toc aven a publié cet été son
premier ouvrage le bruit du bonheur une
aventure débutée il ya deux ans pour la
versaillaise
à un moment j'ai eu envie de me
consacrer à quelque chose de plus
personnel parce que les ateliers on
travaille ensemble il n'ya une véritable
émulation mais finalement on ne
travaille pas sur sur un seul projet
puisque les thèmes c'est le coach
qui désorganise et donc ils sont
différents à chaque fois et ils sont
inhérents à l'animateur lui-même inspiré
du vécu de l'auteur le bruit du bonheur
n'est pas un roman autobiographique pour
autant il raconte l'histoire d'alexandre
un père de famille déboussolée par la
mort de sa mère et le divorce avec sa
femme sa vie va alors prendre un nouveau
départ lors de l'été familiale suivant
et des vacances avec sa fille
adolescente
il va se retrouver à l'occasion des
vacances d'été pour la première fois un
peu en tête à tête avec sa fille qui
elle est adolescente et et voilà et là
c'est un peu la relation père fille
qu'il va découvrir à l'occasion de ces
vacances
et dans leur maison familiale il va
découvrir un secret de famille un secret
familial à succès plus de 500
exemplaires du bruit du bonheur ont été
vendus depuis le mois de juin louvre âge
autoédité est disponible seulement via
internet fin de ce journal rendez vous
demain 18h pour une nouvelle édition les
replays sont disponibles sur notre site
internet et demain il sera notamment
question de politique avec le lancement
par les républicains de la campagne des
législatives dans la 11e circonscription
très belle soirée
[Musique]